guys i think you broke me
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by mila kunis she's a
golden globe nominated actress whose
decades in hollywood include legacy tv
shows family guy and that 70's show as
well as award-winning films like black
swan and forgetting sarah marshall her
latest though are the animated series
gimmicks and stoner cats which were
successfully funded by nfts and
accessible to token holders mila kunis
welcome to the show
thank you for having me i just realized
that the one that i said i have at home
is yours yeah right you probably have i
didn't even realize i think you must
have brought it home and then i i was
like wait i have the hot ones so you
have like a little bit of a foundational
experience with the show what's going
through your head how are you with spicy
food before we dig in here i feel like i
made a mistake by saying yes to this i
do enjoy your show i think it's really
funny i love watching people on it i
didn't think that i was ever gonna do it
my husband did it i had fomo but then
today i was like oh no i have a really
low tolerance for spicy food
so my fear is by the time we get three
and i'll be crying this is my my literal
feeling and all of maybe foreign because
i know i can do this one foreign well
there's no turning back now are you
ready to get started no
[Music]
okay
you go first okay
[Music]
that's so spicy
okay
[Music]
that's fine but it's spicy
so i want to start by unpacking your
latest projects donor cats and gimmicks
because the idea of distributing and
creating a show using blockchain
technology is kind of mind-blowing how
would you explain the model of
connecting an audience to a tv show
through nfts to a dope like me
i know it's really bizarre and i myself
have only been in it for maybe about a
year
stoner cats we couldn't get made
for the way that we wanted it for the
amount of money that it cost to make
the animators come out of pixar the
directors at pixar it's a beautiful
handmade animation
and it was impossible to get made in the
industry as a show
content-wise it's also very r-rated and
i don't know where would go
i became a fan of the crypto community
through my husband because he's been a
part of it for so many years and that's
kind of how i learned about it
and i was like well maybe they'll
embrace this absurd idea
so gimmicks for instance is on a
turnaround of every two weeks and every
episode will end on a cliffhanger it's
choose you on adventure in our community
that owns the nfts will be able to
dictate where the show goes at the end
of every episode and that we never would
have been able to do in like at
netflix's or any streamers or broadcasts
traditional television
[Music]
okay
that's spicy uh-oh
wait
that's like
all right no that's fine
wait no it's not
okay it's okay how much of it am i
supposed to eat i don't want to be like
a big baby right and i don't want people
to be mad at me at the end of this so
like
tell me do i take more than one bite you
know what you're doing right now is
great you know it's all about the
intended effect of the sauces and i can
tell that you're catching them all
you're soaking it in you're becoming my
mouth is on fire with the sauce so what
you're doing right now is fine why are
your eyes not watering and mine are
watering i'll get there i'll get there
you know i just have lots of practice
but i'll get there
okay did you grow up eating spicy food
no you know my dad was kind of a salsa
purist so there was like no mild salsa
in the house like if we're watching a
bears game or something like it would
have to be that hot salsa so i feel like
i had a little bit of a baptism by fire
but this was all just about uh creating
a disruptive element in the celebrity
interview i just had to like become kind
of a hot sauce it's hard to think when
your mouth is on fire are you from
chicago yeah oh we're from so i was born
in evanston and then grew up in crystal
lake which is further northwest yeah i
was about to be like do you know my
girlfriend
like as if there's like two people in
the world of evanston okay got it i love
chicago it's the best it's the best so
when we had kristen bell on the show we
had our fact check dax shepard's
interview and then now that you're here
i think it's only right to run some of
the finer points of ashton's hot ones
appearance off of you to get kind of an
insider's perspective okay bring it so
while preparing for steve jobs he talked
about getting severe back pain and a
fear that he'd given himself
pancreatitis because he was drinking too
much carrot juice what's your lasting
memory of the ashton kutcher steve jobs
amalgamation
oh he's downplaying it he was so dumb he
also i think only ate like grapes at one
point that fruit diet yeah it was so
it's so stupid um we ended up in the
hospital twice
with pancreatitis
so fact check yes it was really dumb
and then the interview was almost two
years ago to the day and at the time he
said that he just gotten rid of all of
his trucker hats an entire wardrobe from
that 70s show can you confirm or deny in
the presence of trucker hats and suede
jackets in the household today
what are you talking about
you didn't get rid of anything
you have plenty of trucker hats and the
entire 70s wardrobe is downstairs what
do you what is this
lies
[Music]
why don't we dip these you know like the
hot dog guy dips it in water and then
swallow why can't we dip it you know
there are no rules so feel free to
iterate here i'm gonna see what this
feels like strategy okay
[Music]
i feel like i just took too big of a
bite
you took a baby bite
that's messed up thank you i'm on it
[Music]
the other one was spicier
[Music]
that's the psychological game of hot
ones you know what we're doing so we're
shifting on you it's a whole spice
symphony you don't know what's coming
are you people shooting me right now i
know you're you're [ __ ] with me a lot
i'm an endless well of uh of hot sauce
facts this one's not bad there we go
hops
totally fine
so in describing the process of working
with you to design your family's la farm
house home
powered back and said we talked about
everything from beam sizes to the
details of the cross bracing to the
junctures of the wood planks and
concrete is there a detail of your home
that you're particularly proud to have
your fingerprints on and then is there
one that serves as a reminder that
marriage is always about compromise
oh really good question
um
when we were building out our island i
insisted on having a dog inlaid like
built-in
little dishes for the dogs and built-in
food you know for the dogs and so
everything kind of looks beautiful and
clean and nice and neat and the dogs
always have a permanent place instead of
me tripping on their dog dishes or
whatever
so to me that was like one of those
where i was like i really want a
built-in dog eatery um
and then as far as making compromises
yes i am five foot four on a good day
my husband's six foot three
our house is built for six foot three i
am at all times on tippy toes and so i
felt like that was a really good
marriage compromise i made i have
ladders everywhere i have a ladder in
the closet i have a ladder in the
kitchen i can't reach things
well speaking of ladders and taking it
up another rung are you ready to move on
okay to the next sauce
los calientes here in the four spot one
that you're familiar with yep
okay
[Music]
i'm waiting for you all right all right
i'm catching up
[Music]
i'm really proud of myself how many were
down four in four look at me go
okay so the stoner cats manifesto has a
stated goal to be supported without
having to bow to the machine of big
media yeah in what ways has the process
of finding funding through the
traditional hollywood channels and what
ways do you think it's maybe jaded you a
little bit over the years it's all of it
sucks
you're you're constantly trying to
people please you're you're just you're
going in and you're being like look at
this i swear it's really good i promise
you it's really good and then the person
sitting across me goes yeah i think it's
really good but i gotta talk to the guy
above me then they go and take your
information regurgitate it to the guy
above them and then that guy goes yeah
maybe let me take it to the guy above me
and then by the time that telephone game
ends the project has now been taken
washed over transitioned and so
it's a process that just is not fun at
all times
when it comes to like nfts it's direct
you can bring it up to the community be
like hey we're gonna make either this
show or this show you decide so on one
hand you have a lot more responsibility
but on the other hand i don't i don't
have to go and like sell myself to other
people other than my little community
that we've built
i'm just reading it to see what like key
words are in there like death
fire
okay you go oh you did it oh you're a
god i'm uh
i'm on cue
now this one
if you tell me it's about to hit me
isn't it is it late oh there it is oh
weird
[Music]
it's a step up
i can't feel my tongue
i can i can i can feel my mouth
i can't feel my son
i don't like this one
okay what's alright i got a nice long
wind-up for this one because mila kunis
we have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that graham we do a deep
dive and i guess instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context
you have sworn off social media but we
have a workaround with the gettys so
what we'll do is we'll show you the
picture over here on the monitor you
just tell us the bigger story oh there's
a monitor there we go do you have a
favorite dodger stadium membership cute
we are waving the flag at game six yeah
i mean that's a pretty good one i love
the dodgers right but i think that i
love the idea of the dodgers even more
so than i love baseball um i grew up
watching the dodgers i used to go with
like my second dad his name is bill
curtis and he used to take me to dodger
games
and when i made enough money the one
thing that i kept from the age of nine
to however old i was when i bought
season tickets i was like one day by
season tickets like one day that's that
was my goal was to just be able to take
bill to a dodger game that to me was
like the greatest memory of all time but
then my husband and i going and taking
the kids our daughter's seven
i'm not getting emotional i'm just
getting pepper in my face
um so that to me is another good one but
this was unbelievable yeah i'm the doug
out there
yeah all right last one for you can you
give me one pro and one con of being
neighbors with conan o'brien oh my god i
love conan other than like he's just
tall and creepy when he's just like
punching it no he's i don't have a con
conan is one of the greatest have you
met him no but i'm dying for him to do
this show yeah i'll help you get him on
the show he's he is he's just conan
there's nothing there's no other
secondary version like who he is on his
shows is who he is in real life and so
often talk show hosts are like one way
necessarily and then sometimes in
private they're very different conan is
just even keel normal family normal life
normal human being um
i love conan o'brien
[Music]
well that just does ghost pepper and i
feel like we shouldn't eat that
[Applause]
that is good
okay
you know what it's good for yeah sinuses
yeah it does it clears the sinuses a
little bit you're feeling alive you know
it's like a senior lechuga is muy fuego
so
for somebody who is at the ground level
to what do you attribute the resurgence
of family guy like how do you think it
went from being on life support and
cancer
the community at large felt like they
had ownership in the show because they
loved it so much and they brought it
back what do you think would surprise
fans about how it was made early on when
it first started on a shoestring budget
it used to all be hand-drawn by seth
mcfarlane
so that's probably something that people
you know and we had nothing we were like
the poorest little like step kids it was
very fun yeah but yeah it always kind of
seemed like that like when you wear many
hats like that like like our set people
like oh that's so genius you can pop
that up wherever but i was like oh it's
just because when we started we had no
money you know that's but that's how
we look at family guys sometimes i walk
in i was like look at our real offices
like we never had
offices right it's pretty amazing yeah
20 years later i was like look at us
look at us with all our offices
look at us hey look at us look at us huh
who would have thought not me
super hot peppers and bitter orange well
i mean that's a selling point
[Music]
okay go
okay that's delicious whoa
i was not expecting that
i mean my mouth yeah is on fire
but it's delicious well i'd like that
you can appreciate the uh culinary
profile here i can't feel my lips
i think i have a tongue in my mouth
i think it's swollen but it is
i really like that one there we go
yeah i really do well maybe it's because
i'm numb because i've burnt my mouth off
and so this one maybe it's just kind of
oh it is yeah
right well hopefully that helps you out
a little bit for the next one too
how accurately would you say this is a
ridiculous interview like and now i
understand this is so this is so weird
oh my god i can't breathe
okay
hold on yeah how accurately would you
say bad moms depicts the cutthroat
internal politics of pta meetings
i support
the moms in our pta
but i don't think
okay
friends with benefits as a very meta
rom-com like it kind of pokes fun of the
genre throughout be careful
what do you think is a quality that
separates a good rom-com from a mediocre
one
ooh
that's a great question
chemistry i think that the two people
have to like enjoy being in the same
scenes together and enjoy being there
i think that it has to be relatable it
has to be aspirational and it has to
serve as a purpose other than just you
need a man or you need a woman
all right
mila kunis
my mouth is on fire this is insane how
do you keep talking
this next one
is to bomb beyond insanity
[Music]
this is the worst joke ever
okay you go okay
why are you eating so much of it
[Music]
oh hell no yeah
[Music]
oh my god i can't this is this is not
funny i know
going through it going through it i'm
right what do i do i'm right there with
you can i drink ranch dressing yeah yeah
we have uh whoa
coming undone here yeah
there you go hitting the ranch
the first time
well
no
that's a bad idea
i'm going back to this okay
me too i know how it goes
i think you're lying
[Music]
on the topic of your world of warcraft
obsession at what point did you realize
that you were in too deep and needed to
quit cold turkey
when my agent would sign on to talk to
me
oh my god i can't this is impossible
yeah yeah when does this go away
it'll be a kind of a diminishing returns
thing it's it's a it has a half-life so
it'll it'll keep getting better like as
bad as it is my heart is racing is the
worst that it's gonna be
what does it mean to be a frost mage
okay a mate is it class and frost made
you throw ice instead of fire because
five
fire mazes fireballs and ice maze
freezes you
that's how i was
both
and i had pigtails
and pink hair right now maybe it would
be nice to have that sort of
oh my god
yeah my name is also captain janeway you
know what that's from yeah i do and it's
a rather poetic segue this is something
that we're gonna get to here how did
salma hayek do salma hayek was great she
didn't even blink on this one did she
and you know what mila i like i like how
you're providing the exclusive because i
think salma's after you
i think
i think this just killed my insides this
is not gonna be fun coming out
[Laughter]
i have to keep eating
well you know what i can't i can't
what's wrong with you you don't have to
do anything you don't have to do
anything
nah man we're doing it hell yeah
figure out how
this next one is how fire's cranked
i have it's not coming out of my house
okay
we'll just cruise there we go
this is [ __ ] nuts
so on the topic of of a tall house i've
read that you'll keep a secret stash of
cereal out of the reach of your kids
yeah what is your mount rushmore of
cereals like your top four cereals of
all time
this is [ __ ] nuts um lucky charms
kicks
excuse me
excuse me
um
oh like cocoa puffs there we go one more
and then like cocoa rice krispies and
then what makes the flannel cakes at
muso and frank's different from just
like regular pancakes
well poop with him
guys i think you broke me
they're really thin
i love new stone franks those are best
y'all they make really good martinis
not like with your flannel cakes because
that would be weird that's yeah but at
night time
can i have ice you can have whatever you
want you can have whatever you want
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing that's a bad
tradition
who did it who did it first uh i believe
the credit is due to machine gun kelly
whoa
and the legacy of that
has taken us seven years in the future
to the final wing with mila kunis
my hands are shaking i'm on fire
[ __ ] you machine gun kelly
[ __ ] you and your traditions
how much you oh i just put a little just
just a little bit just a little bit
i feel like my whole face is on fire
okay a little bit
okay
okay like that
oh wow
let me numb myself yeah yeah take your
time take your time on on your
on your schedule meal
okay
oh
[Music]
yep that's awful
but the good news mila is we've reached
hot ones the final frontier a 10-wing
mission to explore crazy new hot sauces
and we want to close by going boldly
where
has gone before
we've explored the many eccentric sides
of mila kunis from nfts to world of
warcraft but i want to close with your
star trek obsession yeah and hit you
with this question
if you were set to explore an alien
planet who would you trust most with
your life would it be captain catherine
janeway or jean-luc before luke picard
i'm sorry i love captain john luke
picard i love captain jane white but i
love captain john picard
my phone used to have a ringtone that
went captain jean-luc picard at you but
says enterprise it was like this weird
like 20 years ago i found this on the
internet and that was my ringtone i love
captains
patrick stewart's hot
well if mila kunis says it then you know
it's the truth and look at you mila
kunis coming in today nervous not good
with spicy food but taking on the wings
of death and coming out on top and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
nothing nothing nothing's happening in
my life my life's on fire right now
oh my god no thank you for having me
this was a blast i learned a lot about
that i don't really love all these hot
sauces
i can't breathe my mouth's on fire enjoy
everything guys i have nothing else to
say ah go go get some hot sauce or if
you have any shows or anything oh stoner
cats gimmicks sixth wall
nfts
[Applause]
was fine
i would have been fine
this
is so [ __ ] up it's it's [ __ ] up
that is evil like i literally i feel
like i'm sweating and shivering all at
the same time did you have this i can't
talk
excuse me
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement hungry for more a
brand new documentary series from first
we feast is now live on the channel you
know this black box it's great for
grilling celebrities over scorching out
chicken wings from week to week but
outside of these walls is a whole new
vanguard of chefs restaurant tours and
do-it-yourself food hustlers who are
taking comfort food to their communities
and beyond from a mom and pop taco shop
that my boy jj reddick calls the best in
the country to a bronx native taking the
iconic new york chopped cheese sandwich
to the streets
without further ado you know the drill
colin roll the tape
when i had my first chopped cheese i
thought this is amazing it's a sandwich
that you gotta be from new york to be
familiar with
we chose to go the plant-based route
when we were gonna open this space no
one understood what we're trying to
build my identity has always been a rule
follower and now with edith i feel like
we're breaking every rule
if we're gonna make it like we have to
be adaptable
food for me has always been sort of like
a pursuit announcement as a young player
my way to explore a city was to explore
the restaurant
you want to make it in the world you got
to start from your corner i'm just happy
to showcase my food to more people you
know identify all the beauty that's
within the neighborhood and bring it out
to the world
[Music]
[Applause]